I won't even doing stand-up now thank
man like about ten years ten years old
you I am early thirty
what are you pregnant yeah I'm early
thirty there's not what you think John
Jasmine cuz listen if they're doing some
high school movie and they need the dumb
do you still can't graduate it I want to
be that dude guys yeah yeah so you never
want to let the a jaw nah uh where you
from I'm from Los Angeles south-central
adjacent wow yeah wow yeah because if I
think South Central you're gonna think
of a your favorite scene from like Boyz
in the hood a baby boy and I grew up
where they kept the craft services okay
many blocks away from the scene like I
was growing up I got it but you can see
it look at Sears yeah see where what
happened exactly
you like don't go down there it's crazy
down there it was too blurry to know who
was a good dude in the bad dude God you
know that's okay I like that I just
learned something new today
adjacent um you feel like there's a
difference in your style of comedy
because you're a West Coast base
standing comedian I'm definitely because
I mean I feel like I'm an LA dude from
you know I care about how I look there's
a certain way we talk be enunciate you
know I don't know what that little that
supposed to mean you know you know la
guys we talk this way okay
you know properly improper okay or
something but you know I don't have that
girl nothing's wrong I know if I'm gonna
agree with that I don't have that I'm
not like he's Cosby son I don't have a
drawl I'm just like that la hire him
immediately oh you know I mean I want to
show y'all some pictures of James from
back in the day I were James first
started doing comedy okay let's look at
the Hat this with me that's chocolate
sundaes first impression first
impression that's what you get three
minutes and then they're like no more
and I took it straight to the face okay
like three months just let's back up and
let's it not I mean Paula yeah I did
yeah the old miserably a you guys stayed
with my jokes and you go they did not
land
I think anything to the pro I didn't I
took silence and disappointment so there
you go all right now we're clear I'm
about to set you all to enter the next
level man
this is big one of the biggest moments
in your life right now oh yeah and I
want you to treat it as such yes sir I
don't want you hitting the stage those
pants off oh no this thing is a sage
outfit oh they're business they've got a
whole different Arsenal of apparel
that's gonna be just debuted with the
material I feel much better now watch
can you do okay okay well go on
[Music]